alex sa qual è la soluzione all'enigma
ricordagli regole del gioco sanitario
italiano di sanità stress oggi video un
po diverso dal solito che forse non sarà
molto allegro vi dobbiamo parlare di una
cosa che è successa parola io già mi sto
divertendo
insomma ma non eri molto allegro quando
parlavamo di questa cosa comunque
evitare pensa che sia tutto uno scherzo
però stiamo un po spaventando vi spiego
cosa è successo iniziamo dall inizio se
vi ricordate un po di settimane fa è
nato un video di un
youtuber non so chi sia si faceva
chiamare mister hicks ma ora c'è scritto
mister viper virus non so il motivo
cambio di nome forse per non sa dirci
qualcosa sta facendo sul serio verso
prima solo 66 poi va bene arriviamo poi
magari ti chiedo il 47 questo video in
cui questo hacker come dice lui hr
enigmista vitale sempre allegro disse
che non si capisce molto bene comunque
ora lo rivediamo assieme dice che non è
contento con youtube italia perché non
ci sono più animali che va bene ci può
pure stare
sì nel senso noi siamo molto animalisti
quindi capiamo il discorso ma perché
dovresti minacciare le altre persone
solo perché non hanno degli animali ci
sarà qualche motivo del perché non li
hanno cioè ad esempio noi non ce
l'abbiamo perché non possiamo purtroppo
mag secondo caritativo avremo una
fattoria intera vabbè comunque fatto un
altro popolo ma se andiamo a rivedere il
video assieme ma perché ne sto parlando
realtà non volevo parlarne per non
dargli troppa importanza perché mi
sembra non lo so mi sembravano che sta
scherzando o lo fa per scherzo oppure
vuole avere un po di attenzioni e
comunque ho visto che voi sotto il suo
video avete scritto cose che avete
scritto e ma non ha risposto a nessuno
quindi
non so quali siano le sue intenzioni
comunque perché ho deciso di parlarne
perché questa persona come lo dobbiamo
chiamare per vivere mister x virus ha
fatto un altro video in cui ci siamo noi
ora andiamo a vederlo assieme andiamo a
vedere infatti ho voluto fare questo
video appunto per parlarne è anche per
chiedergli a voi cosa ne pensate
e andiamo prima vedere il primo video
che ha fatto che facciamo capire
qualcosa
cerchiamo di capire anche che cosa che
cosa c'entriamo noi e che cosa vuole da
noi pronti
iniziamo con il primo video
un gatto
[Applauso]
allora ha detto questo nuovi statuti
youtubers sono ma misterix perché se
stesso mi servì allora cari monaco non
ho capito niente quello che ha detto
mai come ora non ci affascina sentiresti
disinteressamento verso gli animali non
interrompe era un portale con con
presenza di animali con molti animali ed
è diventato un bacino di in ultime sfide
challenge si sta scherzando orografia ha
[Musica]
detto che ci sono tanti canali senza
nessun animale
lo so che tra poco ci sono animali
abbandonati sono milioni di prima di
fondare allora prendere possesso
disturbarsi capirete presto che posso
sistema convincere più persone ad avere
un animale ma perché con questi metodi
non si capisce molto bene forse voi
capite qualcosa in più se date nei
commenti se avete capito qualcosa in più
del perché vuole fare quello che vuole
fare che non si capisce in realtà che
cosa vuole fare perché non disse
chiudere i canali dice disturbarli oddio
mio pozzo altissimo quindi il video si
chiama primo enigma mister viper virus
che sarebbe
il suo nome primo enigma vediamo cosa
che a me ma io non c'è non l'ho messo
per te se stai guardando il video mister
b non ho messo il pappagallino perché tu
hai detto di mettere un animale perché
ci piace
dopo che all'inizio che non è vero ma
noi non è che volevamo imbrogliare ti
facciano di pensare che avessimo un
animale vero cioè non abbiamo neanche
pensato a tuo video quando l'abbiamo
messo lì allora cerchiamo di capire ogni
punto i tuoi video non rispettano le
linee guida nel nigmi st bettino nel
frattempo si è girato dall'altro panico
non è d'accordo con persone poco serie
ricorrere alle linee guida sono il fatto
di avere un animale non va bene per
risolvere gli enigmi potrei chiedere
aiuto ai tuoi cari ma nessun altro al di
fuori di youtube right place avrà il
tempo per risolvere gli enigmi
ma se non lo risolverà incanto renato
verrà chiusa lo sa lui voglia di dire al
24 ore su scritto qualcosa non saprebbe
ricordo tutto
e ancora se ti rifiuta di prendere parte
al gioco il tuo canale verrà chiusa
a me doveva rimani ecco l'enigma cattura
il mondo simile appare ma non è reale
quindi tipo un indovinello se la
soluzione vuoi trovare tutto il mondo
devi entrare a fare ma non è reale
l'associazione lasciare tutto il mondo
devi entrare il mondo simile appare il
mondo degli affari
stesse mani marino nella milano
una signora
e forse dice qualcos'altro adesso
qualcuno se la soluzione
il mondo simile a fare ma non è reale se
la soluzione puoi trovare in quel mondo
di diventare pezzi qualche qualche altro
indizio possibilmente quel mondo di
entrare in quali volato nel senso in
qualità del mondo appare simile ma non è
reale internet youtube però è reale e
assolti il mondo sì me lo scrive tesi né
atex che ne risultano scrivete il cine
commento non c'è scritto e quale sarebbe
la data di scadenza di questo
indovinello quindi allora non ha detto
quanto tempo si vuole in genere né il
film sono 24 ore di tempo tipo e poi
aveva fatto neanche 48 sforzi averne
tipo in genere sono 24 ore e quarantotto
ore ho fatto a produrre o allusioni te
proviamo a chiedere ad alexa una ressa
saluta la saluta ciao alex sa qual è la
soluzione all'enigma ricordagli regole
del gioco
non posso darti le soluzioni al primo
enigma purtroppo non trovo la risposta è
la domanda non posso darvi la soluzione
all'enigma lui aveva detto che posso
chiedere solo ai fan non ho nessun altro
e come solo alex ma questo non è non è
una persona
alex è stata hackerata c'è stata anche
la val s
si spegne la ci sta ci sta ascoltando
dall'ex può essere perché questi
dispositivi ascoltano in continuazione
lisa tutto dire allora questo è spento
non posso chiedere nessun altro però
posso chiedere i fan e non so se questa
cosa solo uno scherzo è reale e 12 voi
scrivete
secondo voi qual è la risposta a questo
enigma il mondo mondo simile appare ma
non è reale se la soluzione vuoi trovare
in questo mondo di rientrare private
scrivete nei commenti
tutto quello che vi viene in mente come
soluzione aiutateci
e comunque faremo un video non lo so tra
qualche giorno in cui leggiamo le vostre
risposte e speriamo che lui che
sicuramente starà guardando anche questo
video sarà contento con la risposta ci
lasci finalmente imparziali scrivete
tutte le vostre risposte di commento a
noi sicuramente voi che siete tantissimi
riuscirete meglio a capire quindi scrive
tesi tutte le vostre risposte nei
commenti e nel prossimo video andiamo a
leggerle o vediamo magari quello che ci
sembra quella più giusta briamo che il
tempo non finisca tipo troppo in fretta
e speriamo che ci dica qual è il tempo
almeno comunque vi terrò aggiornati
scusate se questo video è stato un po
diverso dal solito
non spaventatevi troppo
non vi preoccupate a voi non può fare
niente per niente mi raccomando scrivete
le vostre soluzioni nei commenti
e non vi mandiamo un abbraccio enorme vi
ringraziamo per il vostro grazie ci
vediamo domani con un nuovo video
ciao